[Music]
you want to guess the color of my
underwear you want to know what I got
going on down there is it Pretty in Pink
or all see through is it showing off my
brand new lower back tattoo you want to
put them in your mouth pull them all
down south you want to turn this
out that's what I'm talking about
in your mouth pull them all down south
you want to turn this out that's
what I'm talking about yeah try it it
lick it SP pull it to the side and get
all up in it we po might remix it send
it to the day I think he's with it try
it it lick it SP pull it to the side and
get all up in it might remix it send him
to the day yeah I think he's with
[Music]
it you want to G color of my underwear
you want to know what I got going on
down there is it Pretty in Pink or all
see through is it showing off my brand
new Ro back tattoo you want to put them
in your mouth pull them all down south
you want to turn this out that's
what I'm talking about you want to try
ity it lick it sced it pull it to the
side all up
in remix it send him to the day I think
he's with it
think he's with
it
guess yeah
gasas gas gas gasas
gasas how much money I just
took the pass to my Google Drive you gu
the address of the party
hey friends I hope you enjoyed this flow
session I really enjoyed making it real
quickly if you'd like to get a set of
those uh pop and flow poy that I was
using in this video you can do so and
get a discount on them when you use the
promo code drexfactor
10224 that is drexfactor 10
12024 checkout over flowtoys.com
that'll get you 10% off your order and
it helps out the channel so everybody
wins thanks so much to flow toys for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to get out and flow also things
have to go out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyroar light
toys and Ultra poy for helping them make
the videos on this channel possible uh
you can learn more about all these
amazing CH uh companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel that is peka pekonen thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission and
finally this video and all the videos on
this channel would not exist if it were
not for my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thanks you all rock and
if you enjoy the videos that I produce
and want to see me make more of them
there's a quick and easy way to do that
and that is to sign up to support this
work over on patreon you can do that
over at
patreon.com Factor poo where you can
also get access to a whole host of
amazing rewards so do go check that out
please and thank you if you'd like to
check out more videos of me flowing out
with various kinds of LED po I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
in flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace